Isaiah Thomas believes to this day that
he was left off the dream team because
Jordan didn't want him on the team yeah
the way Jordan retells the story is also
one more thing I want to touch but the
Atlantic City trip during the playoffs
with the next but uh so the way Jordan
tells story is Rod Thorn calls him who I
guess was the head of basketball
operations calls him his hade we want
you to be on the dream team the pros are
gonna play he goes who's gonna be on the
team and that parently Rod Thorn goes
the guy you're thinking of is not gonna
be on right and the way that they shaped
the story is the way they shape the
story is that there are multiple players
that had a problem with Isaiah yeah and
they just didn't want to be with him for
a few weeks if they didn't have to yeah
and I mean I find it interesting that
multiple players had a prophet Isaiah
and not Jordan Jordan was just as
competitive I'm sore Jordan wanted to
break [ __ ] wills just as much
maybe Isiah wasn't good enough for how
annoying he was yeah where Jordan was
you just had to respect him but it
seemed to me and it could be biased
again watching a documentary it seemed
to me that that could have been how it
went down did Isaiah had soured his
relationship with several of the players
that would be on the team and for the
betterment of the team and the
experience there they're like well we
just take that one bad apple out
everybody else gets along we talked
about this a little bit on the patreon
first of all difference between Isiah
and MJ Isaiah's team was physically
brutal Michael was a [ __ ] mercenary
killer mentally verbally destroy you
[ __ ] Isaiah was an [ __ ] and
everybody behind him would hurt you and
it's like it's not all Isaiah it's not
on Isaiah but he's the leader of that
and also probably [ __ ] that whole team
there's no other Pistons on the team
except the one guy who probably could
have vouched for him and got him on the
team the head coach of the [ __ ] dream
team is Chuck Daly also head coach of
the Pistons so that's who was so if it's
just one guy no longer head coach yeah
okay it was head coach the pitch
so if it's just one guy who seems to
have a pretty good relationship with
Mike because I think he shook Mike's
hand in 91 Mike's gonna remember that 89
90 whatever Mike's gonna remember that
Chuck could have gone to Mike and say
hey man I T whatever let's have a
conversation question do you think that
Chuck Daly relationship with IT was
soured Oh cuz he got fired I mean you'll
think that IT could go to the
organization and maybe it's a different
time I think like we're looking at this
documentary and I think a lot of the
questions we have come from a place of
not understanding the power of athletes
back then versus now athletes had way
less power the fact that Jordan couldn't
get Reinsdorf to fire Kraus is
mind-boggling
yeah it really couldn't get it to happen
he had said I'm gonna get that got fired
and then it didn't happen right if
labrum wanted anybody fired yeah fired
and he simple as that I mean any star of
any team could probably get a GM fired
any any star especially a star of like
Michael Jordan's caliber it's shocking
you know and that's probably what
changed the power from owners to players
maybe cuz it's like it happened you
chose your exam over the players and now
you see how the Bulls have gone since he
left
yo that's great this is what happens
when you choose the GM over the player
the player leaves the [ __ ] league
twice when the league needs him yeah he
see we can't let that happen again
yo give them more leverage and then
that's what really [ __ ] up a lot of
organizations because they were putting
in these sycophants instead of people
that were willing to do the right thing
and sometimes when you need me to do the
right thing for a franchise you're gonna
ruffle some [ __ ] feathers which also
makes feel that much more impressive
though like the fact that he could he's
the guy that can do the right do right
by the team and reach the player on the
level that helps them understand why
it's right for the team so do you think
Daly had an issue with Isaiah or at
least wasn't that friendly with Isaiah I
think maybe Isaiah had there had been
some strange maybe I was a I thought
maybe I don't personally dislike him but
maybe he's not the direction we need to
go to win I want to get back to the
promised land son they're gonna win no
matter what they know going in there
they're gonna win it's not even a
question like I think what's way I
didn't respect IT as much because it's
like yes he was nice but I think my
dream team
not piss I think he was only nice
because the rest of his team would beat
you up or Jordan say he had that it was
good guy bad guy good copy what he said
in the documentary he's the second best
point guard behind magic yo Jordan's
honest he's like I respect his game and
everything's cool with them the dude is
is one of the best players I've ever
seen second best point card outside of
Magic Johnson right high praise yeah but
what does he say afterwards basically
he's an [ __ ] yeah a lot of guys in
life playing with a lot of something
like that dude I think people
underestimate that they're looking at
this like a vacation and you don't want
to bring someone annoying on vacation
and you all have people that are in are
like friend groups that were like do we
really want to have them come and what
do you need what role is he gonna play
point guard you got magic you got John
Stockton
way forward like that you listen you can
always you don't need Christian Laettner
you know I'm saying you don't need Chris
Mullin there are guys that you could
move around right right like we could
look at the roster and who's even
replace they're replaceable guys on the
team fair enough
right that being said if you're a
douchebag and we got to put up with you
this whole time we got to have a little
bit curring that's [ __ ] up and think
about it they didn't and all the people
on that team really bonded yeah like
big-time bonded all the stories that
come out about the dream team are these
like interesting relationships that were
built like Patrick Ewing and Larry Bird
were like [ __ ] kindred spirits
yeah they became like best friends on
this trip you know and like all these
cool relationships on obviously Charles
and Michael were close but I think
Michael really found someone who didn't
care if he was famous or not yeah yeah
right he just found someone who just
didn't give a [ __ ] enough that they
could be like normal together yeah I
mean that could be a whole section of
this by itself
[Applause]